hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back let's play eerie
now here are you right there what are
you doing what you doing what you what
you up to what you going on what's going
on I let you go over here got my prey
can can't go in there
Oh get out of here one likes you hey ho
wait um I went that way
I don't know crap oh this is exactly
where I need to place you know okay yeah
here I need to go to the right now okay
loo this look sandy why does everything
look so shiny and like a sunray burst
it's kind of weird actually Kat is it
cat around here somewhere okay what's
this another key why do I need these
keys I don't have any I don't like have
any place to use the keys okay where's
the guy there is that way cool okay here
we go
ah wait am I supposed to be able to go
up here town hey guys how's it going
you see something uh yeah you are
interesting interesting
look going ah so what's up here then
I've got four or five cards eight of
nine notes so I got an e like oh there's
the cat ah OOP nah come on you totes
couldn't get me man totes mix croats me
and that's that's totally illegitimate
whatever what
that guy's just becoming a pain in the
butt oh oh don't tell me I gotta get
loop around the bathroom again okay
there's a cat here so I just don't know
where can't even see I don't have a flat
oh whatever
what was that it talked about hmm
running running running I love the rush
like what kind of a school culture sent
this guy in here by himself
does it mean okay let's bring it down
this way oh no no no no no I need to go
it was something else in here was in
there oh crap I'm gonna die
right no he's not
they don't go that way and go this way I
said I don't need the cat or anything
why I don't know actually don't know
what I'm doing there was another reason
but to go up there beside so let me just
get the cat
I don't know if it's like crucial to the
ending of the game or whatever but
probably not dude don't know why
everything gets yeah when us rent I must
close my eyes real tight so that the
monsters can't get me
OOP there we go warehouse cap I'll owe
me a warehouse cat
sealing cat prisoners cat cat okay
where's Darius Jojo come here come
everybody thank you
let's go this way all right now then
here so don't come here don't come here
cross yourself
warehouse gone by back to the generator
because I know there's more stuff around
here there's gotta be something here
doors
aha Oh can you uh oh that's not good
okay I just gotta good
I got a loop around cuz I know those
other doors come this way please thank
you okay here we go OOP move it up yes
ah I have all G cards that's good that's
good
where are you come on come on boy come
on come on oh you can do it oh you can
get around that corner come on here you
need to get around that corner I mean
very you need to get around that corner
I need to get around hey buddy buddy can
you buddy
please can you uh buddy but buddy all
three are now done bye bye Danny
hi all this wrong uh-huh Oh what's okay
and here we go here comes the big guy oh
hello
man all right so left there we go okay
so now I can go back to that area I can
go right oh no if I go through this here
that's right that's right that's right
that's right and then I go through that
whole area and then downstairs I think
is where I need to go that guy is freaky
I mean other than surprising he really
needs like the fact that he's always
bears something that detracts from fear
for a while you know it just does you
can't be scared of something that's
always there
so here we go now I go down oh no no
wait need I see what's down here first
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing nothing I'm Kat Kit Kat oh here
we go
oh this Prague gonna kill me cuz I'm
gonna get trapped down here all the last
note cool
last no there's the last key card I
don't know that cap yeah alright I hear
him that mr. brie V I don't see this
viewing like ear buds like this just
that um uh movie those credits hey cool
hope nope nope nope nope come in lag
about right I didn't know where the cat
was like could not oh I'm so oh and I'm
out of
and I don't know what's down this way
that's a lot of breathing goodness
gracious
tempting to disable life support oh why
yes please yes yes yes yes yes yes oh my
oh
Laskey there we go master key now I just
got to get out of here follow the arrows
follow the arrows will do boss
what okay will do boss this way this way
yeah I guess I must have forgot that I
laid all these pounds so eloquently then
we go here click click oh why the doors
gotta fit me that way hey man down oh
yeah yeah like that exit door unlocks up
here out here thank you
arrows for pointing me in the correct
direction
ah like a bow oh all in this day is hard
work can't wait to go oh yeah
Lake Erie that was all in Lake Erie yeah
hell yeah
Oh who's the man that was pretty good I
mean I mean it was it was it was pretty
good I mean I do have some like
criticism of the game one the monster
was always there which kind of detract
around fear well I mean it was really
cool that you know you turn a corner and
is popped up there but that was more of
a startle than anything and kind of a
coincidental scare um the graphics were
good made on the Unreal Engine obviously
a lot of work into went into it but I
felt like you missed out on a lot
because you were just constantly trying
to run away from the monster therefore I
mean that can be sort of like panic
where do I go which way do I go but
after the first few minutes that kind of
dies away really quickly it would have
been better if it was like a slower
approach because if like I was sprinting
90% of the time they're like if I
could've been a slower more controlled
approach that would have been better in
my opinion but once again this is just
my opinion I don't make these games I
don't put in the effort and the hours
and the weeks in the month it takes to
make a game on this so good job making
the game those are only small little
things either way it's great game
everyone should try downloads email link
in the description below in case you
missed it my headphones are on the fritz
that's why I'm wearing these and that's
all I got
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye